opinions expressed on this program are
those of the guests appearing on the
program and do not necessarily reflect
the views and opinions of eight news now
or next our media group
i don't think there's any justice for
the victims who are innocent
tonight on politics now nevada's race
for attorney general heats up we speak
with republican candidate tisha black
the culinary union pushes for rent
control what its ballot initiative would
do
and who's opposing it
i cheated joe
forgive me we're not using profanity
video of a clark county school board
meeting draws quick criticism from
republicans what was said during a
school assignment
[Music]
from eight news now
this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler your primary mail-in ballot
should arrive next week just before
early voting starts and 8 news now is
hosting a republican governor debate
it'll be wednesday may 25th at 7 00 in
the evening right here on channel 8. the
debate is being monitored by anchor or
moderated rather by anchor denise valdez
i-team reporter vanessa murphy and
politics and government editor at the
las vegas review journal steve sibelius
joel lombardo joey gilbert dean heller
john lee and guy nora are all confirmed
to take part in the debate
a reminder early voting starts may 28th
for the primary
the culinary union is working to get
rent control and initiative on the
ballot this initiative is just in north
las vegas
it's called the neighborhood stability
initiative if approved it would tie
maximum rent increases to the consumer
price index rent would only be allowed
to go up a maximum of five percent year
to year it's the latest of about a half
dozen rent control initiatives across
the country this year the nevada state
apartment association immediately came
out against it signatures are still
needed though to get this on the
november ballot
nevada's republican attorney general
primary is heating up the winner will
take on incumbent democrat attorney
general aaron ford a few months ago we
spoke with attorney and republican
candidate seagal chatta challenging her
in the republican primary attorney and
business owner tisha black i spoke with
her about the contest
when you talk about being solved on
crime
what are some examples of that in your
opinion so um our attorney general um
testified in favor of a
bill that was 157 pages of the criminal
on this bill
and that bill changed uh bail reform uh
to change it from the presumption of one
should have bail to one should not have
bail
um changed the drug trafficking
limits from 10
grams to 100 grams so if you have 101
grams of an illegal substance you will
be charged with drug trafficking um
whereas before you had to have 11.
um
there's you know we went from a three
strike state to a seven strike state
um
you know in california where they have
950 dollars to um
that you can get away with for organized
retail crime or retail plan here it's
it's it's uh 1200
so i mean there's a lot of things that
the soft that attorney general ford has
done
that have moved our focus away from
victims and on to perpetrators and that
is not it's not good for our children
it's not good for our community
what makes you in your opinion more
qualified to earn the republican
nomination
um
a number of things i so the attorney
general's office is
the largest
office
um the largest law firm in the state
and i have run a law for my own law firm
for 23 years and it is statewide my
opponent has not my opponent is what we
call in the field basically a single
shingle she employs herself and a
secretary
um
and i think she's done very you know
very well for her business as a criminal
defense attorney
or excuse me a yeah a criminal defense
attorney she's largely spent most of her
time
um defending some of our most notorious
criminals in the state of nevada
she defends
dui defense
um
felony drug trafficking um for the last
20 years she's essentially undermined
our police um
the jobs of our the job that ours police
have done excuse me
and wasted taxpayers money so i while i
think she's a good job you know a
criminal defense attorney i just don't
see somebody who spent their life
defending crime and criminals as being
the top cop in the state would you have
pursued similar litigation over mass
mandates vaccinations and other state
efforts that were put in place for
coronavirus
would i have pursued it as attorney
general 100
what i was doing when we were all in
covid was preserving jobs and helping my
client keep their businesses so i didn't
have
i have um
my clientele who is a priority um
it was my obligation as their attorney
to make sure that we were doing
everything to fight against the
ridiculous foreclosures and make sure
that these people who put their life
savings into their businesses could keep
them open
our full interview with tisha black is
available on eight newsnow dot com we
also have a discussion with her
republican opponent segal chatta both of
those are under the politics tab under
news on eight newsnow dot com
clark county school district is now
investigating a mother's claim about
pornographic assignments that her
daughter was given to read one in
particular the popular conservative
twitter account libs of tick tock sent
out this video this week it's from the
may 12th school board meeting the libs
of tick-tock account bleeped one word
now we're going to warn you we're going
to play this uncensored version
this will be horrifying for me to read
to you but that will give you
perspective on
how she must have felt when her teacher
required her to memorize this
and to act it out in front of her entire
class i don't love you it's not you it's
just i don't like your dick or any dick
in that case i cheated joe
forgive me we're not using profanity
now that woman was allowed to go on with
her complaint but she couldn't keep
reading from that paper the video
sparked condemnations from republican
candidates from joe lombardo running for
governor adam laxalt for senate
guinora who is running also for governor
as well the state republican party ccsd
says it is still looking into the claim
but it was written an assignment written
by another student we have a full link
to the video at
eightnewsnow.com from the 8 news now
i-team nye county commissioners have
voted to move its courthouse it's a
decision that comes after concerns were
raised by judges about guns and weapons
being allowed in the county government
building last year the commissioners
unanimously voted to remove a judicial
order banning firearms in that nye
county complex the complex houses the
district court and trump justice court
judges believe they're sitting ducks and
that weapons should not be allowed in
the building commissioners say the
judge's order banning weapons and guns
violates second amendment rights
why are we not enforcing this
and putting the judges in their place
why are they allowed to do this when
they can put people in prison for life
and we can't do anything back
some commissioners say moving the courts
a good move anyway because it's running
out of space a county attorney warned
commissioners taking the gun issue to
the high court would be expensive but
they added moving the courts would be
costly as well
nevada's congressional delegation is
still pressing the mine administration
on solar tariffs the white house is
looking at solar panel imports from
malaysia vietnam thailand and cambodia
cambodia congresswoman susie lee says
the end result could be higher tariffs
nevada's solar industry employs about 6
000 people companies say about 70
percent of those jobs would be
threatened by those higher tariffs
next year on politics now finding out
what's out there what was said during
congress's first public hearing on ufos
in 50 years and our own george knapp
helps us break down what we learned and
what we didn't learn from
welcome back to politics now
we want to know what's out there as much
as you want to know what's out there
for the first time in five decades this
week congress held its first public
hearing on ufos
defense officials told lawmakers on
capitol hill they have 400 reports from
military personnel of unidentified
flying objects while they can explain
some well they can't explain others
washington d.c correspondent alex limon
was there
in the first hearing of its kind in 50
years defense officials confirmed
sightings of unidentified flying objects
or as the military calls them uaps but
we have detected no emanations
within the uap task force that that is
that would suggest it's anything
non-terrestrial officials said there
have been no collisions between u.s
aircraft and the objects but there have
been 11 near misses and have we
attempted to communicate with those
objects
no
we don't even put out a
alert saying you know identify yourself
some of the objects like the triangles
in this video were later classified as
drones but defense officials said there
are sightings they still can't explain
the defense department says it is taking
reports seriously and that it continues
to expand its office that's gathering
and analyzing reports of ufos it's not
about finding alien spacecraft but about
delivering dominant intelligence some
lawmakers said the sightings could be
evidence of secret u.s or foreign
technology but california congressman
adam schiff was unsure there was
something there measurable by multiple
instruments and yet it seems to move in
directions that are inconsistent with
what we know of physics or science
against the wind the wind's 120 west
after the public hearing a classified
version of the hearing on ufos continued
behind closed doors in washington
alexandra limon
might be fair to say a lot of the
discussion about ufos in washington
wouldn't be here wouldn't be happening
without the reporting of our own george
knapp george good to see you john all
right so uh
just the fact that these hearings even
happen is a big step what did you take
away from what you saw on capitol hill
with regards to ufos well you know i am
a glass is half empty guy i'm
pessimistic by nature but i would say
and i told people you should temper your
expectations about what this hearing is
going to do but even it was lower than
the bar that i set which was pretty low
to begin with the fact that it happened
at all is amazing you know it's been 54
years since the last public hearing
and you know the public is interested in
this they've made it pretty clear over
the last couple of years
since january of 2018 there have been
multiple behind closed doors classified
briefings for members of congress
started with their senior staff members
armed services and intelligence
committees and then expanded as it
became kind of a hot item on capitol
hill it may be the only bipartisan issue
on capitol hill these days because
lawmakers of both parties have come out
of these briefings and they look like
they're deer in the headlights kind of a
look after they've been shown videos
photos documents files things that the
public has not been able to see yet but
you know in general when they come out
of those things they've said this is
really important that's why we had a
public hearing
that said
that's the good part the bad part is
they didn't tell us much of anything
they had two guys there who are
basically spokespersons who clearly did
not have much of a command of the
history of the topic didn't know about
really big cases at all i don't get the
sense that either one of them have ever
been out in the field under the actual
investigations they're telling us things
they learned from other people and that
was kind of a disappointment so this is
just lip service
yeah which is what this has been for 75
years you know uh i i call it uh sort of
swamp gassy because that was the the
famous explanation for a ufo case that
project blue book came out with years
ago oh that must have been swamp gas and
people see these things in the sky and
damn good and well it's not swamp gas
they've demanded transparency for a long
time that's become more of a battle cry
over the last couple of years and i
think the public in general was
disappointed by what they heard
what would you like to hear what do you
think the public deserves to hear and
know about ufos and all the information
you've obviously seen
what what do you want to hear the
government acknowledge
well these guys were asked point blank
hey what other programs existed between
project blue book which ended in 1969 at
atip which supposedly ended in 2017 they
said there aren't any that is just
baloney it started here the reason
they're having a hearing in washington
is because the research the
investigation that started here in las
vegas harry reid gets the 22 million
dollars for a program called ossap it
was managed by the defense intelligence
agency they put together the biggest ufo
database in the history of the world two
hundred thousand cases these folks are
completely unaware blissfully unaware
that any of that information exists they
put together by the way
the best investigators in the world to
tackle this boots on the ground kind of
people
that we've talked to a lot of them and
those are the ones you want to hear the
guys who have been out in the field
doing the research who've collected this
information who've seen the videos
tell them
let them tell congress what they've seen
you mentioned late senator reid
obviously you spoke with him a lot about
this issue and making this public
is it possible this is just sort of the
opening salvo this is the beginning and
there's more to come that's what i hope
i really do hope that i mean
our government our military in
particular has studied this issue behind
the scenes for seven decades and they've
told us there's nothing to it go away no
big deal they've lied and i guess
probably nobody from the pentagon wants
to stand up and tell the congress or the
american public yeah we've been lying
through our teeth but they have so yeah
i'd like to see
witnesses boots on the ground
investigations the the public wants it
members of congress seem to want it and
the pentagon is not going to give it up
unless the public and congress make them
give it up so yeah i hope this is just
the start all right not over yet george
good to see you again appreciate you
john
watch george's many years of covering
ufos on either the i team page at
eightnewsnow.com there's also
mysterywire.com there's a lot to see
next year on politics now staying in
america a new bill in congress to try
and protect documented dreamers
plus legal side hustles how kenneth
state lawmaker worked for a prosecutor's
office a new state supreme court ruling
sheds some light on that issue next one
election headquarters
you're watching politics now
welcome back can county prosecutors also
serve in nevada's state legislature it's
a question two nevada supreme court
justices gave a partial answer to this
week it came in a dissenting opinion on
a sexual assault case state senator
melanie shibley is the prosecutor
the defendant appealed the prosecution
saying she shouldn't be able to write
the laws
and enforce them and two justices agreed
the other five say the separation of
powers case which is underway should be
handled separately
still this gives some insight into how
at least two of the justices are likely
to vote in that separation of power's
case
now that case also involves state senate
majority leader and clark county
prosecutor nicole cannizzaro
hundreds of thousands of young people
who came to the u.s under their parents
visas face deportation when they age out
of the system there are just few options
for them washington correspondent
alexander limon looks into legislation
which could help these young people and
help our job market
democratic lawmakers are pushing for a
bill to protect young immigrants not
covered by daca who call themselves
documented dreamers i'm scared that when
i graduate for my phd that i will have
to self-deport to india they came to the
u.s legally on their parents visas their
parents green card applications are
stuck
in backlogs that are sometimes more than
50
years long once they turn 21 these young
people lose their legal status you now
have to self-deport to a country that
you may have no recollection of if they
remain in the u.s they become
undocumented immigrants more than 200
000 documented dreamers across the
country who are living in limbo senator
dick durbin says the u.s needs these
soon-to-be young professionals think
about how many times we've been told we
don't have the workforce we need we're
desperate to find people to fill the
jobs while congress has been unable to
pass comprehensive immigration reform
for decades this group of democrats is
hopeful that this more narrow
legislation has a real shot at passing
the bill would allow people like millie
herrera to apply for green cards aging
out of the system at 21 means disrupting
my path in higher education it makes
applying to colleges a lot more
complicated
and it makes my future a moving target
with bipartisan co-sponsors supporters
believe the legislation can get enough
votes to become law in washington
alexandra limon
joining us to talk more about this bill
alex simone from our washington d.c
bureau alex since this covers people not
covered by daca can you give us an
example of who would be able to apply
for this
yes so in addition to having to have
been brought here as children by parents
who were you know specialty visa holders
um
in order to be approved these people
would have had to also maintain
residency in the united states for the
past 10 years
they will also be required to be
graduates of colleges or universities
in order to be able to apply for
green cards under this program if it is
approved by congress immigration is
notoriously partisan it has been for a
while what are the sticking points for
republicans on this one
so you know we haven't heard a lot of
opposition at least not strong
opposition um to this specific bill you
know that in addition to i should
mention uh providing a pathway to green
cards would also give work permits to
those who are 16 and older and the
reason that we haven't heard a lot of
opposition is because um as we heard
some of the people in that story say the
united states um needs these types of
future high skilled workers who are
getting this american education and so
everyone kind of agrees that it would
even be you know in the country and the
labor markets best interest to help them
to stay here but what republicans are
saying
is that they hope that democrats will be
able to
compromise on certain issues uh it's
likely that this would have to be you
know rolled into a bigger package that
maybe includes some border security
measures in order to sort of guarantee
that the package would get all of the
votes needed in the senate so
republicans say you know they don't
oppose the bill itself but hopefully uh
they can get some border security
measures to go along with it and then it
is likely that we could see something uh
narrow like this bill pass
all right alex simone from washington dc
thank you very much
president joe biden's job approval in
nevada still very much underwater the
latest civics poll take a look at these
numbers here shows just 32 percent of
nevadans approve of the job that
presidential biden is doing 59
do not approve that is below national
numbers which are 34 and 55 respectively
more politics now
[Music]
[Music]
here's a look at what we're watching for
next week it is of course our republican
primary gubernatorial debate wednesday
right here on 8 news now
sheriff joe lombardo leads in the latest
polling this is though his first
televised debate in this race
this is the first time all five of the
leading candidates have committed to
this race
to this debate i beg your pardon again
that will be wednesday seven o'clock
right here on channel eight i'll be
hosting a debate preview as well
starting before the program at a quarter
to seven
also you should start receiving mail-in
ballots this week for the primary early
voting starts may 28th it runs for two
weeks and then the primary election
that's june 14th just remember you don't
have to go to a specific early voting
location or any specific location on
election day
and we also have same-day registration
here in nevada
it's all happening here before the
primary in june it'll be a very big week
we hope you will join us for that but
that'll do it for us this week here on
politics now stay up to date online at
8newsnow.com we'll back with you
saturday with a complete recap take care